getting the fancy car doesn't make you
happiest and you have to clean the car
or getting a bigger comb out of the city
doesn't you know necessarily make you
happy because then you commute farther
to your work cool
Alexa thanks for joining us on the
podcast days we have special guests I'll
let you do your intro because I'm really
in terrible at introductions but I you
know I'll admit we don't we didn't do a
ton of sort of background research
because I like to just talk in the
moment and actually you know not have
too much sort of prepared in my mind
because then I'm always sort of
referencing my notes and things like
that but I'd I'd rather just kind of do
it more organically but you were the CEO
of learned that hey speak for yourself I
know a bunch of I learned I'm just
saying I personally prefer to do it this
way Sam personally prepares I see he
already knew about it you didn't even do
the research you just already knew so
but for those who don't know what was
learned vest give us kind of like you're
maybe two or three minutes background so
that people know who you are sure I
think so I start from the beginning I
grew up in Florida and when I always
been an entrepreneur love entrepreneurs
love building companies went to Harvard
undergrad and studied happiness which I
I was mentioning because I actually
think somehow it's been very helpful to
life ended up I going back to business
school there dropped out bottom of the
worst recession and originally 81 years
now I feel like this may be a our own
koban moment is is becoming obviously
something that's worrisome but I built a
financial planning software company
called learn bass with a really simple
mission which was so learn best became
TurboTax for financial planning so
literally every American family for an
affordable price could get access to a
financial plan and an advisor and on our
fifth birthday on March 25th of 2015
sold the business to Northwestern Mutual
for about three hundred and seventy five
million dollars and then spent the next
few years as part of that business at
Northwestern Mutual and through it all
that wrote some books that selling book
I called financially fearless and then
financially forward
future of your wallet and I'm just a
diehard entrepreneur I love
entrepreneurs and I love to build
businesses and so now I'm the managing
partner I run a 200 million dollar
venture fund called inspired capital
which is headquarter in New York City
and we pay it forward and we invest in
students Series A entrepreneurs of
tomorrow building big ideas so it's
really fun to get to have them both and
now among the investing side and that's
me and I'm married I live in New York
City I've three beautiful little babies
if a girl dear old and a one-year-old
which means I'm completely crazy but
that's who I am
Wow impressive oh you're not you're not
you're not New York City right now I see
are you I see greenery no I'm not I wish
no so I have been in Florida I'm
actually sitting in my like highschool
bedroom which is which is bringing it
all back full circle where we came we
came down here for spring break and just
haven't come you have like a Justin
Timberlake poster on the wall or
something or what's what's in the high
school room no no but you know it's
amazing look at this I literally I'm
sitting unlike my yearbook which is just
incredible and it's I mean it's so cute
my mom has literally kept like all of
the things and I'm some days I'm like
mom why didn't you serve some of this
stuff away but she kept on my pictures
you know my artwork and hold myself
I'll start because Sam's probably still
blown away he loves Harvard you had him
at Harvard then you sold a company for
three to 75 million bucks and then
financial planning he's a total
financial planning their personal
finance nerd so Sam do you need a moment
to just sort of gather your thoughts are
you ready to go no a little I I did not
go to Harvard I wish but I do have an
odd fascination with it I people say I
have a Harvard sweatshirt people always
say oh you went to Harvard as a kid I
went there I paid money into Couture and
I will just say I while Harvard was a
great education I think there's lots of
things in life that are much cooler than
Harvard did you say ID sorry graduated
undergrad when I dropped out of Harvard
Business okay gotcha and you said you
studied happiness like what is that like
one classic I took a class called
getting rich and
you know that wasn't like my major it
was just one class yeah so I actually I
studied psychology I started in a track
called mind brain behavior and then
ended up in psychology and specifically
there was a happiness lab that Dan
Gilbert was running where we focused on
like how people make decisions what
makes us happy and basically the
headline at the whole you know my whole
experience was really bad about making
decisions that make us happy we do
things that we think will make us happy
but in fact like getting the fancy car
doesn't make you happy cuz then you have
to clean the car or getting a bigger
home out of the city doesn't have you
know necessarily make you happy because
then you commute farther to your work so
it was just really really I think a good
perspective of it's the little things
that really make us happy I love that
you know this is very on topic so so I
remember back in the day there's a guy
who was I think a professor at Harvard
named Sean anchor is that somebody who
was he was I he is one of my teacher
Sean McClure um yeah he's wonderful and
actually um his core professor tall
ben-shahar um and Philip stone were
might might be situated he gave this TED
talk that's pretty great I still
remember it and I'd watch this thing
like 10 years ago that's kind of you
know some talks just stick with you and
it was called that I think the happiness
advantage or this sort of something like
that and if I remember correctly the the
thesis was being happy is actually an
advantage to getting great results some
people think about it the other way like
if a great thing happens then I'll be
happy and his advice if I what I
remember from 10 years ago was if I am
happy I'll have better results is that a
good is that my accurate or am I just
totally misremembering so the short term
is that I'm in under extreme duress and
extreme stress you can outperform in
this short term if you're actually very
happy and relaxed and fulfilled you
outperform the long call so when you're
building teams for long term success so
you know inspired capital to venture
funds we have a really unique group of
people that have come together to build
this firm and we're trying to build a
long-term fund and so I'm there
focus on let's make sure we have
long-term happiness because you won't
perform in the long run and so and the
other thing is I think one of the things
I learned from Sean and tal my my
professors is positive energy and
attitude are actually an undervalued
resource people are very naturally drawn
to people that are positive if you're
super negative over and over people
don't want to be around you they don't
want to work with you they don't want to
show up for you and so I think again you
know one thing people always ask me is
what would I tell high schoolers and I'm
like have a good attitude it goes really
far and it's if part of that point of
happiness is an advantage so is
positivity I always talk about this
enthusiasm is sort of incomplete
undersupply amongst successful people so
you know when you're trying to compete
and you're trying to be successful one
person I'm like the stupidest obviously
you've bought in on this what I'm saying
is that for most people or most
environments I've been around whether
it's like you know entrepreneurs
investors right now I'm at a bigger
company because my company got acquired
it's like the execs at this company in
some ways enthusiasm I think people see
it as like a low status thing to do it's
like oh you know sort of being reserved
is somehow more I don't know prestigious
or powerful in some way and I've gone
the complete opposite direction where
I'm overly enthusiastic and I'm like
dude I have 1/10 of the skills of all
the people that have been around me but
I've been able to go so far because I
think enthusiasm is such a superpower
that most people could tap into and
totally don't for whatever reason I I
mean I totally agree with you and beyond
not only do I totally agree with you I
also think it's worth saying that it is
a skill that we can all adopt right like
just trying to have a positive outlook
it's something you know I can't grow
taller or I can't get better at you know
a certain trait that I just don't have
trying to be positive and trying to be
joyful I think actually it's something
we can all put on it may not be easy for
everybody to do it but it is possible
Sam are you an enthusiastic guy
people like this podcast so we have a
very loyal audience and I think it's
because people feel as though the Shawn
and I have a little bit of a contagious
energy and yeah it is it is positivity
or it's very positive but I I think some
of my co-workers will say that I'm kind
of grumpy because I've got to be the bad
guy unfortunately a lot of times a time
I think you have like an angry
enthusiasm you flip your switch flips
from like in extreme enthusiasm and it's
super infectious to like quickly very
angry or grumpy about something and then
you switch back sort of effortlessly but
for the people around you they're
probably just getting rocked by it
yeah I like maybe you were like this but
like I will fight with my like
executives at my company but then I
think we can just hug it we're good
we're good
I definitely like that um can we talk
about LearnVest a little bit so I used
to I use you guys when you first came
out and I mean I was just I didn't have
a lot of money to where that was like an
issue but I was just starting to use it
what uh what was the premise behind the
business because I think it it kind of
pivoted affair once or twice right um we
started it was that business plan was
always the same
it was content tools and advice and I
started the out of my own savings so we
started with content because back in
2008 in New York City I actually founded
the company in 2007 and you can do a
free newsletter and just kind of get
going and so we started creating a brand
we started trying to talk to our users
and just have a really authentic voice
to say you know for me it was pretty it
was pretty stupefying that I could
graduate from a great school you know I
worked on Wall Street I was really good
at math really good as economics but
when it came to just the basic questions
of my wallet how many credit cards
should I have what's a credit score
exactly and how do I make sure I keep it
safe what are the activities I need to
do and to make sure my wallet is strong
how do I you know how much can I afford
and rent really basic questions the fact
that very clear answers was kind of wild
so we started with content and then we
always said it would be content tools
and advice and so once we finally raised
enough money to build
protecting we started with a budgeting
app I which was a place for you to see
all your finances in one place and then
what we quickly realized was people
wanted advice and I had no idea what
advice look like check would it look
like phone calls call center open 24
hours a day I had no idea and we just
said we'll follow the customers and we
originally started on when you build
content you want to focus on an audience
a specific language so we started with
female Millennials and then what we
quickly by the time we got to advise we
just served households so it was never a
pivot it was very much just like an
extension of what we were doing and by
the time we get to advice we actually
built financial planning software that
could take any family and ingest 60 data
points about them and then would spit
out exactly what we call GPS for your
money so literally a living and
breathing financial plan and we connect
you to I'm a certified financial planner
and we connect people to trusted
advisors that worked full time for us
and so that's what we did and it was a
subscription service and then by the end
we had company is buying learn best
software for all of their employees as a
benefit it you you know akin to your
health benefits and your 401k benefits
and so that's what learned us became we
became the the the largest
fastest-growing online financial
planning company you how long did it
take to go from cotton so I don't know
if you know about my business we're
hosting this pocket it's called the
hustle it's content as well and we're
also building to us how long did you go
so I I'm very familiar with the content
game and this strategy I think it's
great but most people fail at it I think
it's quite hard how long did it take to
go from content to creating your project
products um so we started content in I
May of 2007 is when I founded the
company my then-boyfriend right now he's
my husband his dad was our lawyer so
shout out to him he was the best and my
mom is a secretary
literally like like signed the formal
paperwork I will never forget it
and then I drew the 75 page business
plan and then by the time that I
dropped out of HBS it was December 18th
of 2008 moved to New York and started I
remember I gave myself Christmas I said
you get basically a week and then it's
go time and I so started building
January 1st of 2009 and then by the time
we launched the company like truly
launched our first 10,000 users was the
following January we launched we
launched this thing called boot camp
which for ten day programs that people
could go through to learn about the
wallet and they were free and we quickly
one day realize holy smokes 10,000
people have signed up and week to go
through one of these programs and from
there we just kept building and we kept
talking to our customers and saying what
kind of tools do you want what do you
want advice to look like and one day I
people would write in and say really
want to talk to a customer or sorry to I
really want to talk to somebody I have
questions I had questions and so we then
keep mine as a regulated business to
become a financial advisor and so we had
to go get regulated and became a
registered investment advisor and we
then opened it up that you could pay to
talk to an adviser and we said let's
make it super honest really transparent
no hidden costs just on the site exactly
what it cost and well like you step back
it seems really logical like what we
were doing was never illogical but it
actually flipped the whole industry on
its head the industry used to pretend to
give advice wait for free but then
charge you deeply on all the products
that they would give you and all those
fees but actually be pretty material so
if you had a hundred thousand dollars we
were paying two thousand dollars a year
for advice and that didn't always feel
good people were very distrustful and so
we just said flip it over make it five
hundred dollars for the year to get
access to unlimited advice and we'll
sell no products so we always can trust
that our advice is the right advice and
so that's what LearnVest did and again
it seemed at the time it was actually
pretty groundbreaking to build financial
planning software for everybody and for
the masses and so we also said we'll
take you a few thirty thousand dollars
in income or thirty million um again not
that wild right it's just let's beat
let's be a good business that takes care
of people but what we realize is that
alone
brand positioning is pretty how many
employees did you have like in the first
two years or so to Bill about that uh so
we were small in the beginning you know
we got to about fifty employees but I
call it the first real like two to three
years up interaction that's all you're
hiring a lot of people that's a 50 0 50
is good and by the time we got acquired
we're about 150 people which you know we
were real business and so that for me I
meant just like so much personal growth
so much you know being a young
entrepreneur you don't know what you
don't know and so it seemed really big
to me at times
um but yeah you started launching those
the products in the advice so how cuz
you're what I'll call an audience first
company which is first build it through
content loyalty and then when you have a
service to offer or a product or tool to
offer
you've got your customer sitting there
you just need to convert X percent of
them so how big was the audience um well
I I mean I can't tell you like it's all
from memory by the time we get acquired
we're about 2 and 1/2 million users so
by the time that we when I your video
disappeared we can get me there your
back so there is ok perfect
there we go I don't know what happened
by the time that we got acquired we were
about two and a half million what's the
user uh I was somebody who had signed up
for to make an account so they sign yes
no is I mean and we so it's funny we
were really old school we actually
didn't we didn't ever spend on
advertising we I think by the the year
we got acquired we hadn't even spent a
million dollars on advertising um it was
really old school we were very focused
on like let's let's go and find
customers through business partnerships
and relationships and creating content
and you know we wrote books and we did
all these other things to really build a
following um and then we kept converting
them into that so you know for that for
the tools where people would link all
their finances and we would see their
for wallets we had about half a million
of those and then on the paying customer
side when we got acquired we had about
depending on how you cut it made about a
hundred thousand words on the page - I
mean Facebook was like it wasn't the
same it was different
yes I mean so um
Mark Zuckerberg I went to college
undergrad with me I was hissing
classmate and so Facebook definitely
existed before I was starting wearing
best but I you know 2007-2008 when I was
starting the idea Facebook I think was
founded in like 2004 so he did but it
was very much you know you weren't
building your business on Facebook you
were at Harvard when he launched
Facebook at Harvard yeah so - you
remember when you heard about Facebook
uh do we remember are you kidding you
like could never have forgotten um
yeah I remember at actually at the end
of your username what would be the
number of Facebook user you were and I
was like in the hundreds so I was like
roughly around 150 uh and you've knew it
because it was just the most helpful
thing on the planet it's like oh what's
that person's name again I can look them
up um and I always joked with my husband
when my husband asked me out I like
couldn't look up who he was yet he'd
asked me out before Facebook existed and
I remember being like how I can't
remember who he is like is it this guy
or that guy and it just like my kids
will never know a world where you like
can't look somebody up I mean it's gonna
be a big deal or were you like this is
useful for Harvard and yeah I mean like
could you foresee that it was gonna be
like a seventy-five billion dollar
company um you know I can't take credit
for having like something that was that
kind of crystal ball ish but you knew it
was a big deal um really quickly you
could just tell it was like the amount
of time you were spending on it how
quickly was spreading at when it went to
other colleges and you could look up
you're at those schools when you could
poke people and it was you know to the
credit of market was an incredibly
infectious blog did you know him
personally I know so I did know man we
are an undergrad I met him a handful of
times and I know his family and his
siblings
pretty well but no we need to start by
joining when it was it's like hey this
thing is kind of taking off I'm extra
now Harvard you were thinking about drop
you know you dropped out of business
school anyways to start a business I
actually was thinking at that time of
dropping out of Harvard to start learn
that's basically so my mom convinced me
to graduate I said to her I want to go
start a company I know I need to my mom
was like can you just graduate pretty
please I've gotten into Harvard Business
School my mom was like huge at least
graduate from from college and took my
mom's credit I did I'm glad I did but I
that that itch to go start something was
like pretty alive and I you know to the
credit of like a Mark Zuckerberg when
you are so close to seeing businesses
get built you know I think they called
it the Facebook effect which is when you
can see how powerful the Internet can be
and if you're a you a hardworking person
who has skills you're like huh maybe I
should go do something and but I so
guess and I will definitely say I think
Facebook's spawned an entire you know an
acquired when you guys had I forgot how
many but I've read a blog post which was
like hey learn fist gets acquired for
whatever hundreds of millions of dollars
and it seemed to me when I was doing my
kind of back at the envelope math I was
like so they were doing sort of like as
my math showed me you guys are doing
like less than ten million in revenue
and got acquired for you said three
hundred seven five million that's a huge
multiple so first a might look at I just
did I lose a zero somewhere and then
secondly why did you get such a big
outcome that's what I wanted yeah no
yeah no so we're definitely doing a lot
more in revenue than that but um you
know I think what we developed was a
pretty powerful software so we had about
eight patents on our software we built
cash flow based financial planning
software which didn't exist which is
really silly if you think about it most
of the financial planning software out
there was focused on helping you know
people who were quite wealthy think
about how to build more wealth but it
didn't have to ever net can you pay your
bills but for ninety five percent of the
country you know
now 78% of the country was paycheck to
paycheck so actually that software that
existed would never have worked for the
majority of the entire country and so we
built cash flow based financial planning
software which actually would say how
much cash do you have and can you pay
your bills and if you have something
left then where do we go put it and so
it was a pretty profound technology
platform and in fact I even chatted with
somebody else the other day who's trying
to build like a similar company you
learn best because there's still demand
for these software platforms abide these
big financial institutions and they're
really hard and they're very tedious to
build so so no and then North thrush
mutual also is just an incredible
business and they have you know five
million plus families across the country
that they serve and for them to be able
to take our software and go deliver you
know plans to everybody was a very
powerful concept that the CEO had so so
yeah so that was the first bit and then
the second that's good to know what was
the sort of differentiator that's really
powerful that could drive material
outcomes I know I want to come back to
you were saying that you're talking to
people who are building similar tools I
want to come back to that in a second
but I have two questions for you were
you profitable when you guys sold uh we
weren't like within profitability
meaning like we depending on how we're
spending we were near profitable and we
could have been profitable one thing
that's worth saying we we were
incredibly lean and how we had run we
had just raised thirty five million
dollars so my mandate was to continue
growing and bills out business units at
that time but again I'm a recession
entrepreneur in my DNA we always lived
as though we didn't have extra money and
it was just I you know I think we went
through a moment at post 2010 where was
all about growth and get as big as you
can with no mindsets profitability my
roots first of all are like I'm
naturally you know very very frugal very
scrappy every dollar every dollar we
started spending with my own
in the early days its heist at the
company up and so that was and I read a
few different founders saying that
that's the best way to be a founder and
I I lived it because I felt like it was
the right way to run the business and so
even when we were spending like there
were no dollars that were not going
somewhere I'm gonna get this number this
number will be roughly right but we had
something like forty five million
dollars of cash when we got acquired on
the balance sheet and meaning that we
just we were never spending that so why
are me why raise you so much if you just
raised thirty million dollars you had
forty five million dollars in the bank
that means you had something like ten or
fifteen million dollars when you raised
your last round and if you're making
good revenue why raised in the first
place and also why sell so great
question and so I think first of all
we'd so we'd literally just raised when
we got acquired and North Oxford which
will actually had had just invested and
then they came and said actually we'd
like to we'd like to acquire you guys so
so that's that and then why set so what
we were building I to be able to go get
it to you know our direct consumer
business was growing but I remember
every day we were you know signing up
forty families a day forty households a
day to get financial plans or you know
some days we do two hundred but it was
and I remember thinking we built this
incredibly valuable asset and we built
it because we really believe that it
should be something that should go as
quickly as we can't cross the country
but getting people to financially plan
is really hard it's not like anybody
walks down the street and says oh I
can't wait to go get a financial plan
today that concept didn't exist and I
always joked I actually was selling an
entrepreneur today I was like god I
really did run a hard business to build
which in retrospect I think need it and
like an even scrap your entrepreneur
than I thought if that makes sense like
if I was selling shoes online like holy
smokes how much fun would that be and I
feel like that's an easy business to
build but I was selling something that
was hard right and we were productizing
a financial plan that nobody ever was
super excited about and there was some
part of the population that loved it
you know we were we were telling people
hey financial plans gonna make you
better
and then once they tasted it they loved
it so our customers were super sticky
but I remember thinking to myself oh my
goodness Northwestern Mutual's 8,000
financial advisors that passionately
care about the mission and the same way
I do that can actually go and use this
platform to get to more families faster
and if I really believe in their mission
that's probably the right thing to do
actually for the business is if you
could tell me that I could go from
hundred thousand to five million in a
short period of time and like guarantee
that that would happen like that
actually is a better use of what does
make sense so did the company
Northwestern Mutual did they acquire you
based off of was the the frame or the
valuation based off of how many
customers you currently had or did they
just say that's a we don't really you
know behemoth of a company we don't
really care about your users but what we
want to do is just take what you built
and plug it in on our back-end and yeah
I mean I think and again I can't speak
for how they valued the company exactly
it wasn't part of those conversations on
the back end but I think that what they
viewed it as was they'll say that there
were three really powerful things the
first was an incredible software that
they could plug in that could go to
their customers
the second was our entire platform and
if you go in Northwestern Mutual comm
you know today I was effectively learned
best we just moved over the tech stack
made it so you could log in and see your
finances use a lot of the tools we
launched their mobile apps everything
leveraging all of that and then the
final thing was the team and I think one
of the things I was most proud of is by
the time that I was i you know i joined
the management team but it's toted at
one point roughly a third of the
management team of Northwestern Mutual
was the learn best original team and
Northwest mutual is a incredible company
if you remember you know they do call it
35 to 40 billion in revenue they'd be a
fortune 50 company the little tiny
startup and by the way you know I forget
how many assets app but it's like half a
trillion of assets like they are massive
they're blue-chip they are solidus can
be been here for a hundred and sixty
three years but for a little tiny
startup if they acquire to come in and
be such a big part of the future of the
company really shows you like a talent
the innovation the thinking and then
they got a whole campus in New York City
and they still have today which became a
bit of their digital headquarters i and
again it was 150 people and we've got
acquired but at some point it became
close to five six hundred people that
they were envisioning growing it to to
be there yeah because it just raised I
mean if you said yourself it sounds like
you had a it was a slog a little bit if
I'm kind of reading between lines like
you're like oh my god it's 40 users a
day like this is really freaking hard
wit and they offer you that we're like
yup and or what was that like no it
wasn't that simple and made a handful of
other acquires at the table I and I
actually took my job very seriously
which was my your job as CEO in those
moments if you take your job seriously
and maybe this is just how I'm wired my
job is actually to go get all of the
opportunities and unemotionally bring
them to the board and to say here all
the different paths that we can take
forward and then the board came together
and made a decision of what we thought
was best for us and I actually waited
until that day which was the morning
that we signed to make my decision
because my job was gathering all the
different opportunities to bring them to
the board and say here's what we have in
front of us we can do this path this
path or this path I mean to be crystal
clear it was never like a stressful
decision in that staying private so it
was a really good decision like we had
as I said about 50 million dollars of
cash actually they goes 52 million I
remember correctly of cash on the
balance sheet we were growing it was
starting to get easier and easier
because we'd launched learned best
Network which was growing rapidly and we
were selling the software subscription
in tens of thousands that's way more fun
than you know a hundred a day
um way more fun you're like great I can
do this and that business was really
taking off and it was I just started to
see the oxygen of it um I think the
present I'm making is every minute to
getting there was a lot of work it was
never one of these businesses that just
like overnight 7,000 people show up to
Chipotle and can't wait to eat our
salads like it was it was tough anything
like that but so I didn't make the
decision till that morning and it was
really I took it so seriously because I
had as I said about 150 employees I had
you know hundreds of plus shareholders
if people had been part of the company
at some point left and then all of our
investors and so I had to think on
behalf of hundreds of people and I felt
that your CEO job is actually a really
serious one which is to bring it to the
table and then make the best decision on
everyone's behalf knowing that some
people be thrilled about neck juez ish
and some people big why are you selling
this is such a good business it's going
well and I just also knew it what do you
what do you regret about that journey I
mean are you how would you take back
selling or are you happy with that would
you take back racing all that money are
you happy with that is there anything
that you you're like really well I don't
regret a single thing I have to say I'm
the CEO Jang shil ski at Northwestern
Mutual was one of the best leaders that
I ever have had the chance to work next
to he is visionary and honestly like
what he did I think I'm blown away by as
as big companies think about you know I
ingesting innovation he was really and I
think and how he did a um and I think
there's a another guy named Christian
Mitchell who's the head of strategy and
he was instrumental I actually it really
was his idea the acquisition he became a
best friend and somebody I admire and
you know to take a fast-moving go fast
break stuff start up in New York City
with 150 people who are forward leaning
in every way and then taking a company
that literally is about as blue chip as
you can get the the 163 years I you know
they will live through every major
challenge that we could go through as a
society
and to put us together it was kind of a
brilliant marriage and we always said
what what cemented us was our values if
we believe every American family should
have a financial plan it was a very
simple marriage but it was like it was
the Odd Couple I actually think some
story one day wrote like The Odd Couple
came together um and we felt like we
maybe we made each other better and I
think you know personally I got to grow
a lot through it most times when a
start-up CEO gets acquired they like
sneak out the back door as quickly as
they can and I care deeply that by the
end of it um that I I wanted to make
sure they felt great and I wanted to
feel like I had done what I said I was
gonna do and so I end up saying for
years because I had such a good time and
I think that that that speaks volumes to
Northwestern Mutual which again I was
chatting with a few friends who sold
their business in the last week and they
were like how did you stay four years
and I'm like I loved it and that doesn't
mean there weren't hard days there were
brutal days there were really hard days
uh you know we got down to learned best
brand at one point because it really
made more sense for it to live on the
parent company as a parent I'd been
around for 163 years and learned best
was a tiny little brand and you know I
was proud of that decision also because
it was the right one for what we
promised we're crazy interesting
I know Shawn's good thinking of
something I was just going to say if you
can be this enthusiastic about
Northwestern Mutual you sure do have the
enthusiasm skill mastered so I commend
you for that so what do you what are you
looking at now so you invest now you got
a fund inspired capital what spaces are
interesting to you nowadays
and so so inspired Capital we're an
early-stage funds so seed series a we're
totally generalist we're literally
looking right now at everything from
restaurant tax so food tech which is
really interesting it's a mix of FinTech
and sourcing of any type of food that we
lolly from straight to agriculture
you know farms to your coffee shops that
were pretty excited about we're really
focused on the future of money movement
and there's some really cool things
we're working on there and we are we
just messing the company and the
trucking logistics space which we think
in hope can put lots of people to work
um and so you know really focusing on
what is the next decade gonna look like
we actually published today a future of
works study um
and I heard this great quote we
basically started the year in 2020 and
we're ending this year 2030 just in how
much we have just advanced the ball on
who how and who we all are and how we
will think and you know being a working
mom how amazing it is is it that I can
actually excel at my job truly excel and
actually see my kids probably an hour
and a half to 2 per day more I mean it's
yeah it's I will say I think we're
living through one of the biggest
seismic shifts on our planet right now
ever may be the probably biggest in my
lifetime the global health world is
collaborating in ways that you've never
seen because we are all focused on the
common enemy of kovat and I just think
the world is incredibly exciting and I
will say when you see asymmetric
dislocation like we see right now
because the world is on its tilt
that's when innovators go nuts and this
is like my favorite thing I'd talk to
ten entrepreneurs a day and as you can
tell I'm honestly just a junkie four
founders I love building businesses my
brain loves nothing more than hard
problem-solving and I was just saying to
a founder before this you know companies
have season right you have spring summer
fall in winter winter stocks right and
as I just said I had plenty of winters
that LearnVest
summers when it's fun and things are
exciting and I like to say that you know
the inspired capital team we are our
best when it's winter and for a lot of
businesses right now this is a winter
it's a scary time I was just gonna ask
you you talked about future of work and
you think there's a huge shift going on
I think a lot of people right now are
talking about this remote work what is
what does that mean is this sort of
permanent is this temporary what are the
second secondary effects I'm curious
what's something you know it's the Peter
Taylor question what's something that
you believe about the future work Denton
is not sort of consensus right now it's
not something that everybody is saying
do you have any sort of original views
or contrarian views around the future of
work um I mean I'll just say a few
things I've been thinking about a lot
lately
um I don't know that we I I don't we
will go back to offices so let's be
clear um but I think a lot of the fat
will be cut and what I mean by that is
we use I don't know about you guys but I
used to like be in cabs and running and
ubers and subways and sprinting and
planes and trains and like the frenzy of
what I used to do because there are so
many social norms like if I'm gonna see
you in the city I wouldn't be like hey
let me zoom you right you'd like that's
rude come visit me why like they're so
just I think the amount of what I'm
gonna call it useless friction that we
used to apply to our lives that now
looks calmer so that's great I think you
know I'm really bullish on just
equalizing households I actually think
that this is this is a great equalizer
um everybody's partaking in so many
parts of running a household these days
because we were blocked in our homes and
that's gonna create some permanent
habits but I think our gonna be better
and um you know I I am really fortunate
to have a phenomenal partner and my
husband and we really do both a lot of
everything I around our home and I think
that that's gonna be hopefully more
normalized going forward as I think a
lot of parents are gonna realize it's
not a choice stay home or work like
there's this very powerful middle path
and so you know I think the Greek
economy going into this intermittent
work economy it's just exploding right
now like you can work 20 hours a week if
you want to you can work 70 hours a week
if you want to and I think that we're
gonna so the only thing out I'll say
that's I'm not contented I am deeply
worried about how 40 million Americans
are gonna get back to work and I think
you know the markets right now Main
Street and Wall Street are completely
disconnected
I honestly wake up at 3 o'clock in the
morning wondering how are 15 million
households gonna be absorbed when those
jobs don't come back and and I'm worried
about that a lot so that's one thing
I'll say I don't
I sometimes wonder why more people
aren't talking about what we're gonna do
with the jobs that do not come back
and are you that for is me whatever
what's your background you're what part
of Florida you from I try grew up in
Jacksonville Florida I was born in
Kentucky I grew up in Jacksonville
Florida my mom's side of the family's
from South Bend Indiana my grandfather
was a welder who I once whole life my
grandmother I've worked at AT&T is like
a operator I'm doing the spinning motion
she was literally operator and then my
dad's side of the family
I want oval eyes Belgian and so and then
both my parents were in the Army as
doctors and nurses and so my brother was
born in Germany and I was born in
Kentucky what you sound so you I'm from
Missouri and then I lived in Tennessee
so I'm from a normal family not a
Silicon Valley not a Manhattan family I
live in San Francisco now and I'm deeply
I'm definitely on like the inside of
like a lot of the you know the San
Francisco nerds and it sounds like you
are on the inside of the Manhattan
relatively elite circle I mean the
partner for your for your firm is like a
pretty big deal that fits their family
so you do you just feel ever like you're
an outsider of I mean are you do you
just feel a little bit more connected to
like your roots and you said Main Street
in Wall Street does it feel more like
you're connected to your roots where you
grew up or do you identify more at this
I mean and I say this because I'm in
this crew to a little bit like this
we're pretty elite right like we're like
in this like relatively tight circle I
mean where are you or do you think yeah
I'm so glad you asked this question I so
glad for a bunch of reasons and I think
what's really obvious to me is I think
it is an incredible competitive
advantage um we I think right now we are
in a world where the country is very
disconnected I'm actually hoping that
cope it is something that like does
unify us a bit more those days where I
worry
in the wrong directions there's days
where I feel hopeful and I think the
fact that I came from a really again
like my dad was in the army as a doctor
my mom went to boot camp was a nurse my
mom is a nurse practitioner my dad
passed away when I was younger so my I
was actually raised by a single mom with
three older sorry three kids I've told
her brothers um who are also both
doctors um but like it reminds me every
day that the bubble that we live in is
completely ridiculous and in fact you
know I am a certified financial planner
who stared at America's wallets for a
decade and the headline is people can't
afford anything and everyone's stressed
and if you don't have dignity to be able
to put food on a table for your family
that's what that's a pretty stressful
thing if you're not sure how you're
gonna forget like leaving for retirement
if you don't know how you can actually
think all right now holy smokes
and now that I become a parent like
that's so much more visceral and I
actually think it's a real competitive
advantage to remember that I there's 300
plus million households and this is in
this country and that not everybody is
on the same page and technology is and
always moving everybody forward and so I
think it's a major advantage to not
forget that and again I'm literally in
Jacksonville Florida right now in front
of me dressed in like my childhood
bedroom and I'm so proud of my roots and
I'm so proud of my family and what
they've helped me accomplish and
goodness gracious do I feel like we need
to do more so it's a good segue because
earlier you said that people are
actually still trying to solve the
problem that you were trying to solve
for what opportunities exist in this
financial planning personal finance base
I'm a huge nerd in this I used
wealthfront I used personal capital I've
used mint I use spreadsheets I love this
stuff well first I love you for caring
so I know thank you I mean it means so
much to me you have no idea and I still
honestly have days where that like makes
me so proud you know I think a few
things at
the problem of our wallets for America
is bigger than just like great software
there's a lot of what I'm going to call
infrastructure problems that like tech
can't solve what's the minimum wage how
do we handle you know working mothers
when 25 percent of the country's moms
are single moms and how do we handle
daycare blah blah there's a lot of other
big problems around the wallet in
America that like a cool technology app
doesn't solve that said I don't feel
like learn best solved everything and in
fact I I have this itch that we wanted
to scratch for a long time and around
you know I was a part of the population
where I wanted to talk to a financial
planner that Herning there's a certain
user type about 22% of the country from
our data that wanted to talk to an
adviser in the country but about 78% of
the country doesn't want talk to anybody
they just want the problems of their
wallet to be solved for them and so I
get really excited about the future of
self-driving wallets because I actually
think every hour that you have an extra
dollar penny $10 $100 $1000 it should go
to the exact right pocket instantly and
so I believe more innovation will happen
and I think that's one of the things
that you know we get pretty excited to
talk about is you know I wrote a book
called financially forward literally
just to force myself to think about what
I think of our wallet could look like
self-driving wallet I so it softly word
that every act you've put rules and
controls around it if they my checking
account always needs at least four
hundred dollars in it but every dollar
above that please go put it in the exact
right place and what would you do with a
pair of it would you like I use simple I
like simple calm I've been toying around
with that but what I learned was that
it's it's a checking and savings account
it's actually they use I forget what's
whatever the biggest bank in like the
world is it's like be I forget what it's
called anyway they put their software on
top of another banks checking account
and because it's opening up the bank is
really
is that what you would do I mean how
would you go about solving this yeah
like a fair member correctly simple got
acquired by BBVA um I think actually
right before learn best firm weight less
money of you guys which is pretty wild
um so I think the thing that's um so the
again I don't want to totally bore you
but basically underneath it the problem
with Thomas wallets is money movement
which is money doesn't move quickly from
one bank to another it moves across a CA
trails from 1971 and they typically take
about five days to move the money and so
if you want wallets to actually be able
to self drive you actually have to fix
money movement so we've written thesis
Macomb useless papers I call it actually
liquefied money as the thesis which is
also and I'll give another example why
do we get paid every two weeks how does
that make any sense you work every day
guess what for a normal American family
getting paid every day that's a pretty
radical how cool why do we get paid
every two weeks is this like some
something that I have no idea it's a
concept
some people get paid weekly but most of
us get paid twice a month and if you
think about that people have liquidity
crunches in between those two dates what
do you think every day so under you get
paid every hour that solves that problem
that tries to solve the problem well
they're solving a portion of that
problem so but um but no I think that
there's a few of them there's earning
there's Dave there's a bunch of other
there's a company called even which is
but I'm projects that are streaming
money it's basically like the way we you
know we don't download movie files
anymore and play them we stream it bit
by bit as we watch but basically getting
paid like that so why don't I get paid
by the second that I'm working and it's
just streaming into my bank account
fractions basically of value and there's
crypto companies you know but even are
you both even more valuable okay is not
just the streaming in its then what
happens your credit card debt actually
turns you interest every single night
okay
so actually you pay your credit card
bill nightly
wouldn't materially help save in keep
mind the average family in America has
between 9,000 and $16,000 of credit card
that based on how you cut it the average
savings account is 400 bucks but if
every hour you got paid and then you
could pay your bills and live your life
but it would actually scream into your
401k and get the matching dollar that
same hour and then auto invest think
about that like that is what is the
difference between and I always I feel
like COBIT exposed the precariousness of
our economy but it also exposed the
precariousness of the American wallet
and I think that we're going to be in a
groundbreaking moment of how do we go
fix it so any entrepreneurial is thing I
want to talk to you
Alexa at inspired capital I want to hear
your ideas but these are the big that's
it that's a crazy idea and I think
that's a that's a cool idea for someone
who wants to like it's it's kind of like
a go big or go home that's a pretty cool
idea I like that what would prevent that
from working what are the barriers ACH
it's the infrastructure layer that I was
just saying that I mean is it money
movement or is it a cultural thing
because I'm a business owner I like I
like the two weeks buffer for a small
business when you're just getting
started
like businesses are we take advantage of
that right like you're like like oh
great I've got like five days I got to
go collect this this clients money and
then I can make payroll yeah um it no I
that I think is probable I mean you have
to bleeding-edge companies you know I
think in just the last week we saw a few
companies say I'm work from home forever
but you take a few more that then say
we're gonna pair our employees daily and
in fact uber started playing its drivers
every ride that's that's an example of
you've worked you should get paid why do
why do we withhold from you it's a free
loan to your employer and at some point
that will break down but that's not the
thing I think is harder it's actually
the money movement piece of because our
wallets have been unbundled we used to
have wallets at one place let's say
chase and used to have your credit card
they're your savings account they're
your checking account your 401k cetera
you now just both of you have names
while you've been on this call seven
places that you have financial accounts
so it's money movement across those
accounts moves across
ACA trail that ACA trail takes about
five days or it mimics it and it'll look
like same day and sometimes that same
day is really more of like a magic trick
it's not really there so then to be able
to pay it out to some other place is
very hard so it's the rails and money
movement that European companies doing
something similar helping what was it
called transfer uh there's a company
called transfer eyes but then actually
Europe is miles ahead of us they're on
real time payments rails and you can
actually they like let there they're
like a full decade ahead of us and you
don't even need them no monetary
api basically a mandatory payments
infrastructure right if your notice
called UPI or how much know about
brainstorm ideas we just shoot the [__]
and we brain some ideas where we see
something interesting and we say hey
this is cool these guys are doing
streaming money what would you do with
that hey why do we get I think we
literally had this conversation which
was why do you get paid after two weeks
that's crazy it's a free loan to your
employer and so that's what we do on
this podcast twice a week so that's yeah
we like to nerd out about this stuff so
it's like we know we know a medium a
little bit yeah what uh one of my
favorite ways to brainstorm is I like to
look at companies in other countries and
just be like do that in America
so like Gilt Groupe Kevin Ryan was like
oh I see this French companies doing
this let's just do that in America and
we'll put a little spin on it
what's a European company or an Indian
company that is doing this quite well
that I can go and learn about in order
to see like how this is done because
this is this like pretty hard to
conceptualize right because we're like
it's been done this way for who knows
decades hundreds of years yet I mean to
be honest for the standard of what I
want to see built I don't believe that
there's a company that is closed there's
a couple united states that's starting
to think about this and in doing a good
job also called tally where the jason
the founder is wonderful and it you know
he he was helping people he started with
credit card debt pay off the credit card
debt faster which was that Court mean
and starting automation around it but um
you know I think I want to I want to
like fast forward the decade ahead where
we actually get to Instant Streaming
money it you know I call it liquefied
money you're calling it streaming money
where your money can always be
optimizing to the right place and that
gets pretty powerful when that begins to
happen but most importantly not only is
it powerful it meaningfully changes the
life of American families across
meaningfully so I've heard this idea
before about basically hey what's the
category of what you built it's like pee
pee pee FM or something like that
yeah pfm personal finance manager and
the theory is basically you have things
that clarity money and LearnVest and
others that were basically all like hey
we can suggest some things we can show
you some charts and analysis but like
fundamentally you the user make the
decision and what you're talking about
is the software makes the decision right
self-driving basically like it's not
it's not you're sitting in your car and
your car suggests to you how you should
you know turn or change lanes the car
changes lanes because it knows where
you're trying to get as your destination
and so I've heard before that hey what
we need is for to get that get AI
basically to the point where it can
actually make the decisions and optimize
the money for you so that the user
doesn't have to make decisions user says
I want I have these financial goals for
myself this is my income coming in
here's my bills and it basically does it
and what I've what you added on was the
reason that can't happen right now is
because the transfer is too slow
but it seems like there's a middle step
which is just right now the software
doesn't decide the user decides and most
users don't want to think about that or
make those decisions that most people
are not active with their money
management much to your chagrin I'm sure
so is it more about software deciding
versus users deciding or is it more
about liquefied money um so liquefied
money matters but then to your point
so I'm gonna like I want to answer that
with as with a visual question when we
imagine money right now we imagine money
by saying okay I'm gonna log into my you
know my
you trade a town and I'm gonna stare it
on my grass and and you know look at
things and I'm gonna talk to an advisor
and tell them my goals and then like a
lot of things are gonna be executed I
almost think that we are thinking about
the limits and the sound of what
technology offers today as opposed to
what the customer really wants if you
ask a customer what they really want
they want enough money to do what they
need to do and they want everything else
to be taken care of and like for most
people thinking about money all day long
is two words fun or exciting and in fact
it's quite stressful I'm so imagined and
so I almost think we visualize money
based on what exists but imagine I
thought exercise and I'll use an Amazon
Alexa since I literally there's like 17
in my brother's house and he just likes
to yell at me all day anything's it's so
funny but basically let's use an Amazon
Alexa and imagine you could walk in your
kitchen every morning and just say you
have surveillance so you have rules that
you've set it around your wallet so has
anyone who's broken my identity has
anyone done anything bad or on tour
restrictions that you put on to like my
kids credit cards can youth only you
know spend $50 a month and whatever it
may be and then you've already clearly
laid out goals and it just does it for
you and so you walk in like why do I
even need to look at my money all i care
about is are there any crises no are the
rules i've set up in place so any extra
money you know i need $400 my savings
account for checking for you know if i
need cash we're gonna obviously go away
from cash permanently at some point um
and then everything else just optimize
for me and that's math the thing I love
you know I am a math geek I've always
liked math growing up I always loved it
math is really beautiful because this
isn't you know we're not trying to cure
something a disease that we don't this
isn't a Kovan situation where we don't
know that we don't know what to do yet
we are looking for a vaccine to use that
as an analogy this is math for every
American wallet I can mathematically
tell you where their next dollar should
go to save to save them money make their
life better and outside of them telling
us what their goals are then the math
can do it and it can do it every hour or
every minute and at some point when you
get there that is
for the American wallet and so that's
the vision of that's literally the
picture in the back of my head is like
when do we get to a place where my money
is just doing what it should do at all
times and right now there's wild amounts
of friction move it from here put it in
the savings account sweep it into this
do this with this pay off the credit
card to pay off your student loans you
have to make two payments and tell them
please pay the principal not just the
interest
friction everywhere and at some point it
will go away and I motto services began
and it would be selling my life starts
you're very uh persuasive I feel like
I'm ready to like get behind you and say
let's go to war you're very you've got a
very good pitch I would set these
teachings at his book his book I can
teach you at he's a great guy and I will
say like every financial planner out
there that's doing the work to help help
people I just how I feel I'm not poor
anymore but I will remember be poor and
like so afraid to look at my login to my
bank account and then I eventually
created all these systems so it's like a
little bit of paycheck goes here a
little bit of interest this thing goes
there though there and I'm like I I like
jerry-rigged this thing together and
even to this day I'm still like I hate
logging into my bank account just
because I'm from a year it's like PTSD
right you're like it's so like I just
don't even animate some stuff because
I'm like I don't even want to I hate it
I don't like yeah this is a perfect
example of where you know I really do
think yeah I grew up a really normal
life I grew up in Jacksonville Florida
which is a wonderful place to grow up
and I just think you know I'm interested
in technologies that can impact tens of
millions of families I and like really
meaningfully make our life better and
one last thing you know inspired Capital
we literally invest across all sectors I
just told you everything from trucking
logistics to consumer software to
FinTech but one thing I particularly
like about in tech is in fin tech any
innovation is actually helping the
customer right like you're not
innovating in fin tech in a way that
like gouges the customer it's like there
constantly making their life better and
cheaper and less expensive and the
pressure it puts on the big incumbents
to drive their prices down is really
powerful and I think that's pretty
awesome so I think it's a great place
you already gave your email address I
wish people find you who should find you
how do how do people connect with you I
would say I'm also on Instagram I'm just
Alexa von Tobel our fund is inspired
capital but you can message me on
Instagram and I at the one place I
actively try to respond to as many that
come through so Alexa von Tobel on
Instagram and thank you guys for having
me this is so fun you guys are so
memorable and again really honored to
host out
[Music]